all right exotic
exotic where did you grow up where are
you from originally um
well i just tell everybody all over
because i grew up in like foster cares
and juvenile halls and stuff like that
so i went lived everywhere from long
beach to
[Music]
here in l.a um the valley
iowa
different families
yeah different families different
placements and why did your biological
parents lose you
um two months old
do you know why
um
i think my mom was like you know pretty
drugged out and like also in the game
was it right and my dad was in prison
oh that'll do it
and you went through high school you
made it through high school no
how far did you go to school um
like the beginning of middle school
and
then middle school
i was no longer dcfs i became probation
and i went to juvenile
hall and
from there i just like basically stopped
going to school
and you where'd you go then
um just the streets really
what did how old were you when you
started working as a prostitute when i
started working i was
about like 13 13. yeah that was in l.a
oh yeah
you had a pimp at that time yeah i had
ran away from
one of the placements and
um
like this time when i had ran away you
normally i had ran away by myself but
this time i ran away with one of the
other girls that was in the placement
and it ended up being her pimp
but i didn't know that it was her pimp
so she ended up going back to the
placement and i ended up staying with
the dude
how was that relationship
um
really rough
you've had more than one pimp in your
yeah
how old how old are you
um now i'm 23. you're 23. yeah i just
turned 22. you're still young how many
pimps have you had um i've had
six six yeah
now why do you leave a pimp or what does
he get rid of you or what happens um
every pimp i've left
and it's just because it gets too much
for me to
you know maintain and try to maintain
myself at the same time right now you're
without a pimp right
so maybe we can talk honestly about
about that yeah uh
tell me tell me about the what what it's
like for a girl working the streets to
have a pen
um very like unfair
you know
like because a lot of it just preface
this a lot of my to explain this a lot
of the girls that i interview will say
they don't have pimps when they actually
do yeah because they're trying to cover
for them so yeah so you're not covering
for anyone right now no
so what is your experience with pimps
like it's it's very um
unsettling you know to work that hard
and do some of the things that we have
to do
in order to get the money just to give
it to somebody else and we don't see
nothing out of it but
like maybe something to eat a room
or you feel me our next outfit
our nails done
like
anything that they do give us
goes right back into work so it's just
like we really don't see
any profit from it and you're working
like seven days a week yeah
in long hours right yeah very long hours
is there a quota that you have to make
um
yeah well when i was working for mine it
was it was always pretty much a quota
and everyone that i have worked for i
always ended up being just the only girl
that they had
so even on slow days for me like it kind
of sucked like having to pull in 15 to 2
000
when every date is like 40 60 dollars
you know it gets tough on those days
you're saying you're you're supposed to
make
up to 2 000 yeah but what do you
actually make um
well i've never had a day unless
i was working by myself that
i didn't meet my quota like i stayed out
there no matter how cold it was so
you'll make 1500 2 000 at night wow
that's how many guys
how many dates a lot
yeah yeah
but what emotions does that
bring up in you i mean it's got to be
hard on a woman yeah it's hard like
sitting back thinking on it because it's
just like
you know a lot of prostitutes or girls
that are in the life like
if we tell somebody that's not in the
life or doesn't understand the life it's
like we get judged and
like categorized by that like oh she's a
whole like that's all she's that you
know that's all she's good for right or
that's all she does like it's just like
no it's more sad because for some of us
it isn't just oh she likes hoeing or oh
she must do this because she likes sex
like
no it's bigger than that what do you
think a lot of people that are not
involved in this kind of life
don't understand about girls that do
this kind of work
like some of the survival isn't it it's
it's survival like for me because i ran
away and got involved into it
like
it was something that stuck with me like
it was the only thing that i knew
besides getting a job and doing
something legal and we didn't have much
of an education so exactly and then i
had kids at a young age by one of my
pimps too so how many kids do you have
um i have two
and who's raising them um right now my
grandma
but i have a joint custody between me
and my brother but my brother recently
passed away too so
yeah
so you're working today as a renegade
yeah you know without a pimp yeah is
that dangerous for you oh yeah
especially places out like fig
pomona
like i've done it a few times by myself
out of state
it's not as dangerous because you know
you're a new face but then again it's
dangerous because you're a new face and
so everybody wants to be in the maze so
it was the light-skinned girl with all
the tattoos like
i'm nobody
i'm just walking
and the face tattoos came from pimps
um
yeah
it's like their way of branding you yeah
you try to hide them with makeup and
stuff like that
um
no i never really tried to hide them
from
like makeup
like with makeup um
so show me your face tattoo on the side
yeah i had to speak jordan like about
that big
tattooed and black like jet black it
said jordan yeah and now you've hidden
it with some other desserts yeah so the
only thing that the dude could think to
cover it was a whole bunch of roses
because i already had a rose right here
so i was like all right it's actually
pretty
thank you
and then the one on your eyebrow um the
one on my eyebrow that's actually my
best friend but a pimp got jealous over
it so i
had to cover it
yeah
so yeah
like the day after i got it i had to
stop talking to the dude
um i wasn't allowed to go and see him
um he hit me up on messenger instagram a
few times
and every time he hit me up
like just out of the random
like
i got
i got beat up pretty good for it
just for him hitting me up because
supposedly
you know so the the reputation the
ideas that people have about pimps
at least some of them you would say is
true
yeah for them for the most part
they're physically violent and oh yeah
they'll use intimidation and force and
things like that to control you yeah
you give them all the money
yeah i don't think all pimps are quite
like the ones you had there are some
that are
truly trying to help girls
do what they can with these
you know in this lifestyle but i think
there's lots like especially in l.a
where the gangs are so powerful oh yeah
like i could say that about my last my
last one my last one i ended up like
basically i guess you could say
like turning him into a pimp but he
ended up being my ex-boyfriend and i
just needed like some type of protection
you know because it was a lot of stuff
going on on fig
like a lot of girls getting killed yeah
a lot of people were getting killed
lately yeah so
i feel like very unsafe so i told my ex
like you know if you could come and
watch me and just have my back and make
sure nothing happens like that i'll give
you half of whatever i make and so that
was the only
i guess pimp that ended up being like
fair with me and you know like good
treatment
are drugs are part of your life
um yeah what do you use
uh crystal crystal meth is a popular one
now
yeah
but even now you got to be like cautious
of it because there's been a lot of bad
batches going around like cut with
fennel yeah we'll kill you yeah
is the addiction part of what keeps you
in this lifestyle
partially yeah because you can't really
function outside of this you know
getting a regular job wouldn't
yeah
like i've been on it
like on and off now for three years
because it just like eventually started
putting a toll on me you know
and it was just like the only escape
route like okay boom when i do this
i don't think about nothing else i don't
second guess going out there and working
or none of that i just go out there work
get my money
and i'll be cool because it's like
everything else gets blocked out it's
like you become numb to everything is
your life
distressing or depressing to you
without the drug at times it can be yeah
it's got to be a stressful lifestyle
yeah are you addicted to this life
to the streets um
most of the girls i talk to say they are
to extend yeah it would be hard to just
stop and get a regular job right yeah
because anything that happens or goes
wrong it's like
okay boom if my kids need like diapers
or
you know for me to pay for babysitters
just like okay what do i know that
within an hour i'll have some type of
money to pay for it
nothing else but going to the streets
you know so
are you saving money
um yeah
that's great you're one of the few
that's actually saving money
yeah
well especially now like not having to
give it to somebody or feeling up like
i'mma get in trouble if i don't give it
to somebody
it's like okay now i have priorities and
goals to get out of this lifestyle
because that's the ultimate goal where a
lot of females get
trapped they're like
sidetracked from it like the goal is
to
do it
and not be stuck in it
do it and get to where you're trying to
get to so that way you can leave it in
the past you know yeah
are you lonely it's a lonely lifestyle
right
yeah very long yeah
you think you're you're meeting all
these guys that eventually
you know it would prevent you from being
lonely but i think it's probably a very
lonely life right yeah because even when
you do try and settle down and like get
into
um
actual community relationship it's
like well for me at least it's always
been
that
it's stuff like that that i tend to
bring up to a person
and they end up looking at me like oh
okay that's all you that's all you are
you feel me so you're probably going to
cheat on me and this mad and be out in
the streets and it's just like
maybe if you give me the chance maybe i
wouldn't you know
it's got to be difficult
but what what examples of a loving
relationship did you see when you were a
child
when you were young um you're still
young but when you were younger
not much and when i did
like the only person that i really like
could say i failed or like
you know even got a
clue of what love was from was my
brother who passed away
um like about three years ago he ended
up killing himself
but um sorry
we
we were like the only true definition of
like some type of love whether it be
conditional or unconditionally because
you know like i've seen my mom growing
up like here and there you know and
every time i seen her it was always
something else that had went wrong with
there's some other dude beating her up
or cracking her in the head with a
shovel you know because she went through
his phone
she stole somebody's drugs like your
biological mom yeah
so with her it was just like
abusive love which i think i picked up
innocence too
and like everybody else just
like kind of stayed off and did their
own thing do you feel like you're in
some ways walking in your mom's
footsteps
yeah in a sense doing the same kind of
work and
the drug addiction and
just doing this kind of work um
build up your self-esteem or undermine
it
um a little bit of both a little bit
about that yeah okay
and it's and it's dangerous as well
right yeah very dangerous have you had
things happen to you
yeah
yeah quite a few
um like with us we're told not to get in
the car with younger
younger age dudes
for the simple fact like
a lot of the younger age dudes now
portray themselves to be pimps when
they're really not
or you know
they'll
rob us or
try and kidnap us
um
my last few situations
um
i got in the dude's car
it was a pickup truck at that you know
car seat in the back
so i'm not thinking anything of it we go
down to dark street
go and do our day
and halfway through the day i felt
something metal on my back
and i turned around and the dude had a
gun to my back
so of course like i panicked freaked out
i started trying to
open the door
he had child locked the doors i tried
like banging out the windows
and
that ultimately ended and him like
telling me that if i didn't shut up and
stop banging on the windows that he was
going to kill me right there
so i stopped and i just let whatever
happened happen
he ended up throwing my phone out the
window parking somewhere else
took off the condom
raped me and robbed me for everything i
had made that night and i had to
go and tell my pimp at the time what had
happened
and he's like oh i don't care you know
still go out there and make your track
you say you're back out there yeah
right
yep and then i
my last
um
incident that i had with
while i had a pimp out there
um
like
about two two years ago
um
i ended up getting in the dude's car he
ended up spending all of his time
talking
and wanted his money back and that's
always been a rule with
anybody that i've been with you you're
not ever supposed to give the money back
you're supposed to get the money first
you know if they spend their time
talking or doing something else then
that's their fault type of thing
so i didn't give the money back to him
i told him just drop me back off on the
blade you know
and he drove past the blade and started
going faster and faster
and i think he hit about 60 65
and i just remember opening the door
covering my face
and just jumping out
and like that i thought i only had like
scrape
the skin off of my body but i ended up
going to the hospital about like three
or four days later because my pimp at
the time ended up going to jail
so it was hard for me to get up by
myself and like do
things by myself
because you're sore from jumping out of
the car exactly and so i went to the
hospital
and they told me that it was a good
thing that i ended up going
because i had suffered from third degree
burns
on my shoulder
both of my knees
both of my hands both of my butt cheeks
and my head was cracked open and i
needed
over 30 staples and stitches and i had
to have skin grafts but um
i had to learn how to walk again
how to write
so any job that has this kind of
a risk of things like that happening
most people would just get out yeah and
i did i did for
for a little bit because it kind of like
scared me not knowing
the person's car that i had jumped out
of
and not being able to put a face to it
like okay i know if i see him again i
know not to get in this car because i
jumped out of his car it happened so
quick even though i was sitting there
with him for a good 30 minutes you know
you don't tend to look at somebody's
face thinking okay
he might be the person that i died with
tonight even though that's the case when
it comes to being out there
you're not guaranteed the next
two seconds let alone the next two days
you know your intuition's got to be very
keen right yeah
you won't you don't just jump in
anyone's car exactly
i see a lot of girls just walk away from
certain vehicles
yeah i don't know why they're doing that
but like if the windows are tinted
um if the plates
are paper plates
um or you know the california exam
um
if it's a black dude
like i've even been told like i couldn't
date older black dudes
and it was just like okay like sometimes
i would go against that because it's
like you know not every pimp just sits
there and watches every car that you get
in you know
do you ever say to yourself that you
deserve a better life than this
yeah you believe that yeah that's great
because you do
know what no one deserves to be
putting their life in jeopardy like that
and then getting all the abuse that you
end up getting
yeah
you've been in love before
um
yeah you're only 23 so don't feel
pressure to say yes
no i have been i have been
it went well
um
until it didn't
it
it was hard like
because the dude was the total opposite
from what i was used to you know
all the
fighting and abusive and
you know i went from a dude constantly
pulling my hair and
wait like getting me down on the ground
kicking me while i was on the ground and
spitting in my face to a guy that tells
me that i'm beautiful every time i wake
up and
you know like treats me with respect and
make sure that i'm okay my kids are okay
so it i guess it was kind of like
more on me that it didn't end up working
out
because i started becoming
what they were to me to him
you couldn't adjust to
yeah
do you have any friends
um
no i mean i always say my kids are my
friends yeah you know that's good
how do you think
well i mean you've been doing it since
13.
i was going to ask you how this life has
changed you but
do you feel like it's changed
um who you are
you've been doing it for 10 years now
yeah
yeah definitely the streets always
change people it seems yeah like i'm not
like um
i don't trust people
it's got to be hard out there because
everyone's a hustler
even the tricks are oh yeah everyone's a
hustler
and it's the ones you least expect
to do anything that
ends up being the one sitting there
plotting like oh okay this girl looks
like you know
like she's a little bit skinnier you
know like she can't defend herself so
i'mma go and sit there and plot
something on her but
you know to us they look like normal
tricks so yeah you want to date fine and
then we'll end up in the whole situation
just because
we
we chose to
give him that that opportunity and say
okay yeah he's just a trick you know you
can't do that with everybody right
what is this work that you do taught you
about men
um
i assume most of your
tricks are married
yeah
yeah married or
have relationships
what have you learned about men from
doing this
that um
a lot of them have
secret life like
you would never think
that you could see half of these men
that go on fig
end up having a wife
four or five kids
working a good job
but you come to fig every night
like
it's like if you're unhappy like you
know leave your family like they don't
deserve that they didn't ask for that
you know but
i guess everybody has their reasons on
doing the things that they do you get
crazy requests from some of your
oh yeah like what
um
like now i have a dude
that pays me
just to sit there
and talk about my day for like 10 15
minutes
and he like he'll massage my feet and
take a picture with my feet on his face
or something you know
but it's
it's all right because it's just like
you know i don't have to do nothing i
just have to sit there and let this dude
rub my feet you know did you get guys
that asked you to do it without a condom
and things like that
um yeah we i get a lot of guys like that
but um
to me well
my little mind of thinking like okay if
you're asking me this
and say i was the type of female to say
yeah okay just give me extra
how many other girls have you been out
here doing that with you know and i have
kids so
i don't like to take that risk at all
right no but just just
being out there period yeah your life
could
end any night exactly your kids will be
without a mom
what advice would you give to a young
girl
who's thinking about getting into this
lifestyle
um it's not worth it
yeah
definitely not worth it
what's your biggest regret
um
probably having my kids and going back
to it
just
what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
from
i have like a few like probably not to
let my guard down too soon
like it's okay to tell people
some things about you but
not everything everybody should know
because some people don't have the same
intentions and we use it to their
benefit
and
your weakness
never let like nobody dictate
the person you are
like
don't allow them to have that much
control over you to where you're not
happy or
you know you feel like you can't do what
it is that you want to do in life
yeah it's a tough lifestyle isn't it
yeah very tough
it's not for everybody
definitely not
a lot of people think that
you know this life is
you know anybody could get in anybody
can get out but
sometimes that's not the case you know i
when i was in juvenile hall
um
waiting to get sent to hawaii
um it was
like two or three other girls that i
ended up being
in juvenile hallway
and
the one girl had court
went to court got released
and when she was picking up her property
from
los petrinos uh
her pimp was wading by in a semi truck
and ended up running her over and
dragging her
and
it was all over the news we weren't able
to watch the news
i mean but everybody knew what had
happened and who did it you know
so
it's it's stuff like that where it's
just like you see girls try and get out
of their life but
you have that
one person that's just like no you're
gonna stay in this you know
and it's sad it's very sad
and it makes you second guess getting
out of the lifestyle but
i mean if you really want to there's
there's always somebody willing to help
you know
even when it seems like everybody's
against you there's always that one
person that's not
like i have a niece that's
somehow followed similar steps to my own
and it kind of like gets the best of me
a lot especially
recently
like she's put me in situations where
she's like oh i want to go out there
with you and i'm just like oh no
no you do not like
no what the hell
but she's also caught me at a weak point
and it's where it's just like you know
what [ __ ] it if you don't give a damn i
don't give a damn either
you think you're ready for it go ahead
and
she would get to the point where she was
right about to do it and
it's just like
you know you still got a baby face you
still have your innocence like
all right no that's not the life for you
you feel me like it's
better out there you know
you finished high school go to college
you know do something
make something of your life
and she's actually told me a few times
like oh well i want to be like you like
no you don't trust cause sometimes i
don't even want to be like me
[Music]
but it's sad you know to see somebody
my age once before
coming to me asking me to help her do
the same thing like
i can't do that to her you know
like even some of my home girls now well
they call themselves my homegirls
like oh let me go out there with you and
it's just like no i'd rather go out
there you know than have one of you guys
go out there and something happen to you
you know
not everybody has that street
street wisdom you could say
some people think they could get into
this and
it'll break them to the point where you
know they do end up killing themselves
or
overdosing you know
just like some of these guys they think
that they can be pimps but
behind closed doors you know they're all
lovey-dovey you know i'm sorry i didn't
mean to do that i didn't mean to do this
like
you know you can't lose who you truly
are trying to be something that you're
not
all right exotic thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah i wish you the
best of luck out there thank you thank
you very much
you